les valeurs d'autochtones l'inclusion
l'équité le respect de l'environnement
les priorités du nouveau roi avaient été
solidement imbriqués au cœur de la
cérémonie canadienne nous souhaitons
marquer le début du règne de Sa Majesté
le roi Charles III discours performance
artistique
[Musique]
l'occasion surtout de saluer l'arrivée
du nouveau souverain c'est un moment
pour le Canada de constater ses liens
historiques
constitutionnel avec la couronne à
l'extérieur de la réception quelques
curieux à la recherche d'une façon de
souligner le moment je m'attendais à
beaucoup plus ouais je m'attendais à ce
qui est peut-être des affiches et des
gens dans la rue ça fait partie de
l'histoire et c'est quelque chose
d'important le visage du roi Charles se
fera doucement un chemin dans le
quotidien des Canadiens du timbre à la
pièce commémorative et bientôt sur la
monnaie de tous les jours pour remplacer
le portrait de sa mère qui trônait
depuis 70 ans on va continuer évidemment
à utiliser les pièces qui sont en
circulation ils ont de valeur légale et
on va introduire les nouvelles pièces
alors quand les Canadiens vont le voir
c'est une bonne question on pourra y
répondre probablement plus tard là pour
vous donner une meilleure idée
mais derrière la transition d'usage le
déficit d'affection lui demeure bien
réel au Canada comme dans bien d'autres
pays du commonwear le nouveau roi est
incapable d'atteindre le niveau de
popularité sa mère la reine pourra-t-il
combler cette lacune je crois qu'il va
voyager pour mieux connaître au peut
être mieux connu par les peuples du pays
comme au monde
les gens ne connaissent ce qui est
important pour lui ce sera des idées qui
sont importants pour le Canada aussi
séduire ses nouveaux sujets une visite à
la fois ici Daniel Thibault Radio-Canada
Ottawa